congratulations just another award being
nominated or winning for Beatty Best
Actor Award now I have come to look
forward to a Billy Porter red carpet
moment at an award show and this is
gonna be a little different because it's
gonna be a little zoomed livestream how
did it feel to get that nomination and
where we still be in a cooter Mont I you
know obviously it's always an honor
it's especially an honor coming from
black folks you know the relationship
with the LGBTQ community and the black
community is tenuous at best so it's
always nice when your own people see you
with that said the red carpet you know
I'm actually taking this time to not be
in that space mm-hmm
we'll be back to that space soon enough
you know I'm really trying to maintain
like just a level of self care so you
know I'm aware of soon as I'm a
performer like you who is you know uh
octo threat um you know from the minute
you get out of a car at an event
everyone's watching you you're
performing and then the whole night so
your whole life is a show you're doing
so much especially someone like you
because you are I mean it's a show and
so I love you I'd love to hear that
because I always sort of worried about
the the real show men and show women of
Hollywood because you're always giving
and people are always there feeding off
of you so I love to hear that you're
kind of taking a little time to just I
mean that's what that's what this
pandemic this reset this moment for me
has really really truly been about you
know what does self-care look like for
me in this new reality you know what is
that
because I really do need to make sure
that I'm taking care of myself
so that I can continue to show up you
know because even in the commercial
breaks Billy Porter Sinnott singing a
song give you a break they can never
gives you a beauty and even just take
the bathroom break after Tommy's you've
got to be entertaining the people
[Music]